Katerstimmung heute morgen bei der CDU
in Niedersachsen die Partei von
Spitzenkandidat Bernd Althusmann
verliert deutlich über fünf Prozent
heißt die CDU fliegt mit aller
Wahrscheinlichkeit in hohen Bogen raus
aus der letzten großen Koalition in
Deutschland ja und Bert Alto ist man
selbst der Chef der Niedersachsen CDU
der erklärt noch am Abend seinen
Rücktritt der Frust ist also groß auch
bei der FDP sie ziehen gar nicht erst in
den Landtag ein die Liberalen krachend
gescheitert an der 5% Hürde tja und auch
klar diese Niederlage ist eben natürlich
auch eine Niederlage für den FDP-Chef im
Bund für Christian Lindner
wir haben heute für die Freien
Demokraten einen traurigen Abend wir
haben ein politischen Rückschlag
erlitten unser Ziel war klar wir wollten
eine linke Mehrheit eine linke Koalition
in Hannover verhindern nach allem wonach
es aussieht er wird die Mitte nicht
gestärkt sondern Niedersachsen wird nach
links gehen das war das was wir
verhindern wollten dass sie da ein
bisschen zerknirscht aus der Christa
gute Laune hingegen bei den Grünen die
fahren nämlich fast sechs Prozent mehr
ein 14,5 Prozent ja und damit wächst
natürlich jetzt die Hoffnung auf
Regierungsbeteiligung in Hannover
Rot-Grün in Niedersachsen das werden wir
was mit deutlichem Vorsprung ging auch
seine SPD am Sonntagabend bei der
Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen über die
Ziellinie bleibt stärkste Kraft und
stellt auch künftig in Hannover den
Ministerpräsidenten Stefan weil schauen
wir noch mal auf die vorläufigen Zahlen
die SPD verliert und zwar mit
33,4% bleibt sie aber die mit Abstand
stärkste Partei deutliche Verluste über
fünf Prozent für die CDU sie liegt jetzt
bei
28,1 Prozent und deutliche Gewinne auch
für die Grünen alle Details alle Zahlen
im Detail jetzt an unserem Touch ja hier
sehen wir es noch mal ganz genau ja ein
bisschen aufgedröselt also die SPD jetzt
habe ich immer weggeklickt so hier unten
haben wir den richtigen hier sind die
Stimmen eben nach Parteien die SPD minus
3,5 die
cdu-5,5 wir haben es eben schon
angesprochen bei den Grünen großer
jubelplus 5,8 wobei tatsächlich sie
eigentlich im Vorfeld noch ein bisschen
mehr erwartet hätten die AFD ja ein
großer Gewinner dieser Wahl plus 4,7
Prozent ja und der große Verlierer
natürlich die FDP -2,8% eben gar nicht
erst drin die 5% Hürde haben sie nicht
geschafft ja linke Platz 1,9 die sind
dann auch nicht mit drin und die
sonstigen kommen auf 3,2 %. da können
wir uns jetzt noch einmal die Gewinne
und Verluste ganz genau anschauen da
knallt nämlich so richtig wir sehen es
hier -3,5 - 5,5 + 5,8 + 4,7 und -2,8
eben bei der FDP kein gutes Ergebnis
darüber müssen wir tatsächlich noch mal
reden und zwar mit Jan Schäfer schön
dass du bei uns bist ja guten Morgen so
groß ist der Frust bei der FDP aktuell
einer der großen Gewinner scheitern an
der 5% Hürde wie groß ist der Frust der
Frust ist extrem groß wir haben das
gerade ja auch gesehen Christian Lindner
hat gestern abend gesprochen es gab
verschiedene Runden in denen er
gesprochen hat aber auch andere
Parteimitglieder und man muss das vor
Augen führen was da in der FDP jetzt
losgeht die sitzt quasi in einer Falle
sie ist gefangen in einer Koalition man
muss das glaube ich auch schon so
drastisch sagen mit zwei Parteien
deutlich links der Mitte die FDP
vertritt ja eher liberale bis
bürgerliche Position sie kommt aus
dieser Ampelkoalition derzeit auch nicht
rausgeht eine große Krise sie ist da
quasi gefangen es gibt jetzt zwei
Möglichkeiten entweder sie macht es wie
Friedrich Hans-Dietrich Genscher 1982
sie geht raus aus der Koalition und sie
macht's wie Guido Westerwelle 2012 der
ist nämlich drin geblieben in der
Koalition damals mit der CDU und der CSU
und wir kennen das Ende das Ende ist
dass die FDP bei der Bundestagswahl 2013
komplett aus dem Bundestag geflogen ist
also ist jetzt eine Wahl zwischen Pest
und kollera niemand würde goutieren wenn
die FDP rausgeht bis auf natürlich die
FDP wieder selbst und niemand würde
diskutieren gerade bei der FDP Basis
wenn sie in der Regierung bleibt das
haben wir jetzt gestern noch mal
Niedersachsen gesehen und die anderen
Landtagswahlen in diesem Jahr waren
ähnlich schlecht für die FDP also das
ist wirklich jetzt extrem bitter für
Christian Lindner ja muss ich
entscheiden raus oder drin bleiben wie
viel Bund steckt denn in dieser
Landtagswahl tatsächlich haben die
Wähler auch Christian Lindner persönlich
gestraft mit dieser Wahl in
Niedersachsen interessanterweise sehen
wir ja verschiedene Entwicklungen wir
sehen dass die SPD verloren hat aber
gewinnt sie ist deutlich über dem
Bundesschnitt aber der Ministerpräsident
muss auch im Vergleich zu der Wahl vor
fünf Jahren deutliche Verluste hinnehmen
die CDU hat deutlich verloren und man
kann sicherlich bei beiden sagen da
spielt der Bund durchaus eine Rolle denn
wir sehen ja auch das deutliche
anwachsende AFD und die AFD hat in den
vergangenen Jahren eigentlich ständig
bei Wahlen bei Landtagswahlen auch
verloren über den Balken nach unten
jetzt sehen wir das nach oben geht das
hat natürlich zu tun mit der aktuellen
Krise mit der Angst vieler Menschen um
ihren Job aber auch um die Frage können
wir eigentlich gaststrom im Winter noch
bezahlen und wir sehen auch natürlich
die Grünen die im Bund auch extrem nach
oben gegangen sind in den vergangenen
Wochen und Monaten also eigentlich der
eigentliche Gewinner der ampelregierung
in Berlin von wem haben die hat die AFD
denn gefischt wo sind sie denn
hergekommen die ganzen afd-wähler unter
anderem interessant sowohl bei WLAN
ursprünglichen Wählern der FDP muss man
sagen da gibt es große Wechsel und
Wanderungsbewegung aus dem klassischen
fdp-milieu
Handwerker beispielsweise genau
Mittelständler ganz genau und wir sehen
es hier ganz genau auch von der Union
gibt es Wähler selbst von der SPD und
auch aus dem nichtwiederlager konnte die
AFD deutlich dazu gewinnen wie ist denn
jetzt dieser starke Gewinn der AFD zu
bewerten
die AFD ist immer dann stark das haben
wir auch zum Beispiel
2015/2016 gesehen wenn es eine große
Krise in diesem Land gibt 2015/2016 war
es die flüchtlingskrise da hat die AFD
AFD mit vielen vielen Ängsten der
Menschen gespielt und hat das Thema
immer wieder thematisiert in ihrer sehr
extremen Art und Weise und jetzt ist es
natürlich die Angst vor einem Winter der
möglicherweise für viele viele Menschen
nicht bezahlbar wird wenn wir an das
Thema Strom und Gast denken und genau
diese Ängste nutzt die AFD auch immer
wieder aus aber da auch ganz interessant
wenn wir sehen die Grünen ja sind nicht
ganz so stark geworden wie sie es vorher
erwartet haben aber immerhin noch ein
deutliches Plus Robert Habeck allerdings
im Bund eben genau für seine gaspolitik
ja momentan nicht besonders beliebt wie
erklärst du dir das in der Tat und ich
glaube da ist die Antwort auch schon so
ein bisschen in der Frage mit drin die
Grünen sind zwar ein Wahlgewinner aber
sie haben auch ein blaues Auge
davongetragen sie lagen Umfragen im
Sommer noch bei 20% sahen sich schon auf
dem Weg fast auch zu einem
Ministerpräsidenten etwas überspitz
formuliert nein aber sie waren deutlich
deutlich stärker und haben natürlich
über die vergangenen Wochen da kommt
Robert Habeck auch ins Spiel deswegen
hat diese Wahl immer auch
bundespolitische Bedeutung kommt
natürlich der der Zickzack-Kurs und das
debake was Robert Habeck in Berlin
hingelegt hat ganz klar hier mit zum
Vorschein die Grünen haben in den
letzten Wochen massiv verloren feiern
sich zwar jetzt aber müssen sich
eigentlich eingestehen sie sind nur ein
halber sieger ist das jetzt also quasi
die die rote Karte für die Ampel diese
Wahl in Niedersachsen ist auf jeden Fall
eine dicke watschende wirklich fette
fette Klatsche die härteste hat
Christian Lindner abbekommen das muss
man so sagen aber auch grüne und auch
die SPD können jetzt nicht so tun als
wenn alles wirklich super wäre das sehen
wir an den Balken der SPD da deutlich
nach unten gegangen ist und das sehen
wir auch an den Balken der Grünen der
lange nicht mehr so stark nach oben
gegangen ist wie er noch im Sommer vor
zwei Monaten gegangen wäre da steckt
viel drin in dieser Landtagswahl danke
schön Jan Schäfer
[Musik]